new russia collusion probe in washington
this one involving hillary clinton the
House Intelligence and Oversight
Committee is launching an investigation
today into a uranium deal struck with
Russia while Clinton was Secretary of
State
here's Republican Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez we're here today to
announce is an inquiry into Russia's
involvement into the uranium deal that
was done several years ago this is just
the beginning of this probe we are we're
not going to jump to any conclusions at
this time but one of the things as you
know that we're concerned about is
whether or not there was an FBI
investigation was there a DOJ
investigation and if so why was Congress
not informed of this matter and another
probe launched today into the Obama
Justice Department's handling of the
Clinton email investigation more on that
in a moment but first hillary clinton is
fighting back against allegations she
colluded with the russians while
Secretary of State she's of course
blaming Republicans and Fox News for the
focus on the questionable uranium deal
with Moscow it's the same baloney
they've been peddling for years and
there's been no no credible evidence by
anyone in fact it's been debunked
repeatedly and will continue to be
debunked but here's what they're doing
and really I have to give them credit
you know Trump and his allies including
Fox News are really experts at
distraction and diversion so the closer
the investigation about real Russian
ties between Trump associates and real
Russians as we've heard jeff sessions
finally admit to in his testimony the
other day the more they want to just
throw mud on the wall and I'm their
favorite target me and you know
President Obama we're the ones that they
always like to put into the crosshairs
okay so famous sleight of hand by
Hillary is that the scandal has already
been debunked and it's just a conspiracy
theory that's what happened with
Lewinsky
Gazi the foundation pay-for-play do you
think that defense gutfeld will work
this time I would say a distraction
would be like bombing a country to
divert from a sex scandal that would be
just go back to the most obvious point
is how do you buy your rhenium we are
obsessed with buying drugs on the
darknet or guns from private dealers and
the story is about buying uranium I mean
it's will we gonna have a new William
Devane commercial like now has never
been a better time to buy uranium what's
in your nuke it makes no sense to me
that that that that's not that's not the
big question the next question is will
the network's cover this investigation
with the sweaty exuberance that they
covered with the collusion because this
really is a bias exposure flashlight it
will expose to your team sport like if
you like Hillary you won't do this and
you hate Trump you'll do that so it's
it's it'll be interesting I say
investigate everything because it gives
us more segments we've had plenty of
Hillary segments this time I'm gonna use
a sports analogy for you know a cooler
warning the Clintons don't have a lot of
blockers out in front of them you're not
in the white house Obama's not in the
white house there's no Democrats
controlling any of these investigative
committees though Jared they only have
the media do you think the media is
gonna be enough to stop these
investigations well no the
investigations are gonna go forward
because of it once they start something
and they start an inquiry it will happen
I do wonder at some point is her book
tour going to end that is the thing that
I think that most Democrats would think
this is were in the seventh week of a
book tour the interviews she did was
with c-span book TV great book she's
making a lot of money off of it but
every single day the reason we have
segments about this is because she keeps
talking it's true because she hadn't
talked and we probably wouldn't have
maybe put this down in the e block but I
also think that just to be a refresher
on this the way that you sell uranium
okay that's actually a very good point
but it has to go through this thing
called Cepheus which is the committee
for foreign investment in the United
States and it's all sorts of cabinet
agencies have to approve this so it's
not just like the State Department signs
off its commerce Treasury
energy department others and put down a
deposit don't you it's like getting it
it's like any one of those big vacuum
cleaners at the supermarket I guess it
is possible yes that the Sophia's
committee did not know about the FBI
investigation I that might be one of
their excuses on the committee was Eric
Holder and his Justice Department had to
have been aware of the FBI investigation
right thing you could imagine though
that they might say oh well we didn't
know it didn't work its way up to the
top I don't know that would be a pretty
lame excuse but it might be the one to
come up with that's right we were joking
in the before the show Kimberly this
might not be the sexiest scandal uranium
sisyphus just doesn't have the typical
Clinton scandal ingredients he's made it
sound like a communicable disease this
will stick Hillary or do you think she's
just gonna get away with it like usual
well she's already pivoting and trying
to provide explanations and she's out
there and and also she's a little bit of
a sitting duck as she continues to try
to promote her book and make appearances
so then she's open and right for these
types of questions and as the evidence
continues to develop and proliferate
there will be more questions for her to
answer in terms of what she knew when
and what kind of collusion there was so
this actually already seems to have a
lot more like meat to it than anything
you had to do with Trump and with
Russian collusion so fair fair play we
want to look into this and about
dealings with Russia this is an
appropriate investigation especially
like Dana said that it passed through is
to make sure what they knew did someone
try and push it from there in the
Treasury Department etc to say let's put
this deal through on you know kind of
like a bro deal like Oh scratch back
scratch back I would like to say know
that there above you to approach and
that type of thing and really operate
independently but you don't know that's
why you have these committee oversight
hearings so that we can actually get to
the bottom of it and drill down to say
wait a second who knew what was hillary
directly involved was a surrogate from
her in a meaningful capacity in a
relationship aware of this and tried to
put it forward was this something that
the obama administration let go through
since you know long people feel hillary
got the election taken away from her
when she could have been the nominee
with him with the franklin commemorative
who knows one if I was asking Hillary
question this is what I would say
Hillary Russian oligarchs and about a
hundred and forty five million dollars
to your foundation do you think that's
because they wanted to help cure
diseases in Africa or do you think
that's because they wanted you to sign
off on their uranium deal well it can't
be the latter because she wasn't
Secretary of State when the overwhelming
amount of the money was given to the
foundation
when was that so it was more than
eighteen months before she became
Secretary of State doesn't work
foundation no but I'm saying then she
becomes secretary and signs off on it
that's usually how it works she doesn't
have the power to sign off on it she was
one member of a nine member Commission
his name you keep screwing up so but so
to me this is the news here was that the
hill reported this week that in fact you
had a number of people who were Russian
mobster billionaire types who suddenly
wanted to influence the US energy
industry were making contributions and
all and so that was new that we know oh
gee the Russians are involved here
because we knew about the money flowing
and it's more than 140 million that went
to the Clinton Foundation Peter
Schweitzer reported in this long time
ago the New York Times is reported on it
it has been examined nothing has been
found and as I say the timing is way off
Jessie this the problem is the timing of
these donations why do you think these
Russians donated one hundred and forty
five million to the foundation well no I
think they're trying to buy influence
and they're trying to raise their
stature here in the United States so
that they can have political favors but
they didn't do it in such a way that you
could say oh we've got evidence now of a
quid pro quo involving Hillary Clinton
what we've really got here is what
Hillary Clinton said Republicans who
decide you know what it's time to
distract it's time to disrupt it's time
to divert from the investigations into
guess who Donald Trump and so suddenly
this is the counter offense but does
that make this less credible or less
problematic I don't think so at all
whether you had an investigation into
in Russia collusion and what was going
on at Trump Tower doesn't matter this on
its own warrants an investigation so I
don't think there's me it doesn't matter
if you say well this is the counter to
that oh because you did this to me I'm
gonna do this to you
you know playground play you know is
what it looks like to me well do you say
that this is a credible investigation
it's something that should be
investigated if there's like you I think
what what you're getting at is that the
media has been flipping out over Russia
perhaps purchasing Facebook accounts
$100,000 $100,000 worth of Facebook
accounts and and and suddenly Russia is
inherently malicious it's like in 2016
Russia is so evil that they purchased a
hundred thousand dollars in facebook
accounts but maybe a couple years ago
around 2010 they were so wonderful and
likable we thought they were so great we
sold them 20% of the uranium that's the
story the story is that they were okay
back then so we gave them something that
will destroy the earth but they're
buying Facebook accounts by the way like
six cases of vodka I do for Hillary
because I think that this is her next
career she should do a TV show called
what happened and she just sits there
and she explains everything
like what's of the uranium what happened
well that you could do that to do the
truck and the conclusion of every show
could show like a flowchart yes right
back to the Republican exactly could be
Monica travelgate whitewater the debate
scandal it could be an entire series
what happened 9:00 p.m. MSNBC they need
a host there